[Music]
[Applause]
this is one of the stages where we have
the physical 3d set piece in the
background it's about a three foot tall
model made out of foam and painted when
you take I think there's 180 pictures of
that like around the camera is never
perfect so it has a bit of a wobble
which gives it that old-school feel and
then there was a little bit of
post-production just on the levels to
make sure it matched the paintings in
the background you can see the rock at
the very bottom but there's like quite a
bit more it just didn't end up matching
in the end or had a way to put the whole
thing in but I think this boss see this
is a boss where you knew kind of this
whole thing from the get-go
we knew the distinct patterns and sort
of like the feel and end that it was
going to be a dragon I wanted something
that involved moving platforms as like a
complete different feel from other
bosses that you would normally play and
then for me the classic memory is the
Megaman 2 dragon of the initial chase so
that's it's there's no design in the
dragon specifically to look like it but
we're like then wouldn't that work for
us is clouds and a dragon so that was a
starting point we weren't sure exactly
what we wanted to do for the second
phase where the fire guys run along the
bottom and jump and there was this
thought but it never made sense that we
were like what if he somehow can become
a music dragon and we're like I don't
know turn heart Tambourine something and
like musical notes would run along the
bottom yeah and then we just decided to
scrap it and stick with a more classical
theme
but I know the initial feeling was most
people were like this the hardest boss
its but it's more of like a solvable and
I'm not gonna call it a puzzle because
you still have to play it but when you
realize like less movement on the second
form and then less shooting on the third
form it's not as bad as it seems
this boss was also something just to
test our push the art further we studied
the old mill the Disney old mill short
to like see how they approached rain and
storms and no just did the whole idea of
the the weather change was like we
always give ourselves as many challenges
throughout the game and that's why we do
stuff like water in the harbor stage or
you know crazy splashes on the mermaid
stage we just for some gave ourselves
like many challenges to I guess that's
what I was searching for what's us like
there's a black and white Mickey was one
that's not it's not that ghosts wonder
what the mad doctor unless it is but it
starts like it's a mad dog he's at the
Med doctor that starts outside yeah and
like closes umbrella way and then yeah
yeah we really liked the look of like
how they animated the rain and it was
their lightening effect which is like
just simply flashing away but it looked
so good in that cartoon that we're like
what boss would work well with rain and
how can we throw in a thunderstorm and
then we're like I know it'll be easy
just make the final form change
everything in the background
[Music]
you
[Music]